hey guys my name is clinton jones i am
the punisher
and i am very excited to talk about my
favorite subject
surface imperfections you guys are going
to learn
what they are where to find them and how
to actually make your own from materials
around the house and how to make your
own cg assets i'm super excited for this
we're going to take those assets and
we're going to apply them to our renders
to bring them to life
surface imperfections take on many
shapes and forms they're the worn edges
on metal railings the fingerprints on
your smartphone are the dirt layer that
builds up over your porch railing
they can be the scratches in your
hardwood floor the white marks on a
clean window
or dried water spots scattered across
your shower glass
surface imperfections tell us a story of
where something's been
and how that something has been used
they're all around us and as artists we
need to be very aware
of those imperfections and the important
role they play in making our renders
look real without the scratches this cg
door knob would just look
too plain or worse it would just look cg
the grungy texture on this keypad really
adds to the realism
of the metal and it tells us how this
phone booth was used
and the fingerprints and scratches on
this film camera really take it
to the next level and they're not just
useful in close-ups
if i didn't add surface imperfections to
the boss town dynamics robots
they just wouldn't look good they
wouldn't look real these things have
been tossed around
they would have scratches they would
have grime and dirt on these things
so now that you guys know how important
it is to add these imperfections to your
renders
it's time to get a hold of some now it's
very easy to go online
and look up surface imperfections like
for example this pack of 30
4k 16 bit seamless surface imperfections
that i put together
just for this video the link is in the
description but i promise you it is way
more fun to make them yourself get your
hands dirty
i want to show you guys what i learned
along the way so let's start with the
three basics
all right so fingerprints all i'm doing
here is using an ink pad to transfer
my identity to a white piece of poster
board if you're making multiple textures
be sure
to add a bunch of variation to the
amount of fingerprints consider adding
smears
or entire hand prints to the mix just
experiment and have
fun with this for scratches i'm taking a
wire brush and randomly pulling it apart
dipping that in a black water soluble
paint and very lightly
brushing this poster board making sure
to keep my movement
random and be sure not to go too heavy
on these you know i find that the more
subtle
the effect the better you can always
make like a really heavy
super scratched version you're here you
got your stuff centered
and for dust i'm using flour on black
poster board
lightly sprinkle it over your canvas for
an untampered look or wipe it any number
of ways for
infinite variation so with this pack i
really tried my best
to make imperfections that i couldn't
make with just cg noise
i wanted to be more unique and that gave
me this idea
here i'm using gray paint on my shoes to
lay down a base layer
on a larger piece of white poster board
once i'm happy with the shoe variation
and the surface area covered i'll switch
to black paint
this will give the imperfection depth
when we process it in photoshop
and remember do a few different versions
alright we didn't set
all this stuff up for nothing and what
we're really going for
when creating these imperfections is
contrast you want
black on white you want white and gray
on black
you want to be able to set yourself up
so that you can process it in photoshop
pretty simply now that brings me to
the more advanced surface imperfections
specifically smudges
so getting contrast out of screen
smudges can be a bit tricky but
certainly not impossible so
here's what i did first track down a
laptop screen a tablet screen
or your phone screen could even work and
lay it on the ground next to
a bright light source the brighter the
better get your camera on a tripod and
shoot
straight down you should be able to see
some smudges if you placed any on your
screen at this point
now if not the trick here is to angle
the light to catch the smudges from our
bird's eye view just play with the angle
on the screen
or the amount of smudges if you're not
seeing any reflections in your screen
can make extracting these smudges a lot
more difficult
so what you can do is put a black towel
behind your camera
or what i was doing was actually using
duvetyne to block the reflections
so that's most of the hard part all
right now for the fun stuff let's just
smudge up the screen
as much as you can go for variation here
use the tablet like you actually would
same for the smartphone you know so i
found that breathing hot air into my
hands
made it easier to lay smudges down on
the screen or honestly
just run your hands through your hair
for a little bit of grease and
you know have fun with it it's a good
time so this next step is pretty crucial
what you want to do
is wipe the screen clean without moving
the ipad or the laptop or your phone
the point here is we're going to use a
clean plate to extract the smudges later
in photoshop
so now you just rinse and repeat so you
can use the same setup to capture dust
and fibers that you might find
on the surface of you know items that
don't get cleaned too often so grab some
old
clothes give them a shake and let it
just rain down on top of your screen
so then you just wipe your screen clean
capture your clean plate and move on
so the last method for capturing
imperfections is to just do it natty
meaning you just grab a camera and you
find some imperfections out in the world
and you take a picture of it
bring it in photoshop and process it so
this is the way i'm capturing water
spots
white marks leakage any kind of like
water-based or grunge based effects
so i found these on my shower glass they
really show up in the morning
when the sunlight blasts through or
during the day when the ambient light
fills the bathroom
time of day is very important you just
gotta keep your eyes open
now the same is true for white marks and
splatter on this window
the sun cut through in the morning
revealing these beautiful
cg assets and i found some leaky dirt
buildup
on a sketchy white van parked out front
i grabbed my camera cranked up my
shutter speed
took a shot got it out of there real
quick so before we hop into photoshop
let me just talk about camera settings
really quick first off grab
the camera with the highest megapixels
you possibly can
we want to eliminate as much blur as
possible so that means if you're
shooting handheld crank your shutter
speed so that you eliminate
any motion blur if you're shooting on a
tripod your shutter speed can be lowered
as low as you want
but make sure you set it to countdown
timer give it like five seconds until it
takes the picture
we don't want any depth of field either
so make sure your aperture is like 5.6
or higher and you're shooting
straight on to your wall and shoot and
raw
use those 16 bits it's what will set
your imperfections
above the rest all right enough you
happen let's hop into photoshop i want
to talk to you guys about how to process
these things
and how to make them seamless let's go
alright so let's start with this uh
clean plate business here if you guys
shot raw which hopefully you did
you'll be prompted with adobe camera raw
let's go ahead and select
both photos and hold down shift to do
that we're going to make sure that it's
in adobe neutral for that profile uh
browse w raw w neutral and that way we
actually maintain
all the color tones and values you're
not getting any color correction on top
of it
we'll scroll down and we'll make sure
that there's
no vignetting in our image so we can
actually bring this slider up to make
sure
and correct for that you can bring the
midpoint in if you want to and we'll
just go ahead and open these guys up
so this is actually one of the best ways
i've seen clean plates extracted here
so i gotta give a shout out to mr rob
blight who showed me how to do this
the technique works wonders so big
thanks so let's drag a clean plate
into the smudge plate and you can see
that the angle
you know perfectly matches didn't really
move it moves a little bit but
you know that's that's okay all you need
to do is select the clean plate layer
scroll down to subtract and voila
let's add a black and white adjustment
layer because these imperfections work
on a black to white scale
and let's go for a square crop and
choose the area that we
like the best
so from here we need to make this
texture seamless if we were to tile this
right now you'd see the edges on all
sides
the best way to do this i've found is to
group it with ctrl g
duplicate it with ctrl j and then merge
it with ctrl e so we're working with
just one image but we still have our
backup here
and we need to find out the image
resolution so we'll go to image
image size and you'll see 43 44. 4344
is our number and with that we'll go
filter
other offset and this basically flips
our image
inside out we'll type in half the
resolution
of our image and that'll perfectly split
it right down the middle like this
now from this point we're going to use
the clone stamp tool
to basically patch up these seams here
so s for the clone stamp tool and i'm
going to use the open and close brackets
to
increase or decrease the size of my
brush and we'll go with a low opacity
brush here
so the trick here is to make these
smudges look like they actually continue
as opposed to chopping off at some
random point so you want to be smart
with the way
you fill this stuff in you also don't
want one pattern super close to
the original source you can obviously
tell that it's tiled this way
another trick i like to implement is
making a levels adjustment layer
and cranking the gamma so that i can
actually see a little bit better it's
like turning the lights on
so with this i'm pretty happy so you can
hit ctrl alt f
to redo the previous effect and this
brings us back to our original state
let's go ahead and hit ctrl t
move it over to the side and hold alt
and we'll test out
if it's seamless or not and this looks
solid to me this way we're actually able
to tile this texture as many times as we
want we'll never see
any seams and our renders will go on
forever and ever
so the quickest way to get these
imperfections working in your renders is
to actually pipe them into
the roughness channel here in your
material and you can see immediately
you're getting some really really nice
results
we can go ahead and scale this thing
down
and you can actually lower the gamma
here
to get more of a intense version
of that texture which i always like to
do and you can always add a gradient
and you can crunch these up you know get
that black point down a little bit more
whatever look you're really going for
you can totally mess with this
inside of your program of choice so real
quick before we wrap things up
let's go back into photoshop and talk
about how to process images
that don't have the clean plate attached
so let's use these water spots as an
example
let's go ahead and grab a square crop
there's clearly a bright spot
up here and it gets darker down towards
the bottom
left and we want to even this out so i
want to show you guys a really cool
trick
that i use to fix this so first things
first we're going to do a levels
adjustment and i'm going to bring the
black slider up to the point where
the levels really start you can see the
histogram here the white levels look
like they actually start
where our slider is placed so by
bringing this
bottom slider up it's getting these
black levels here the darkest of darks
but what about the rest of this stuff we
need to bring this gray
down to a black as well so here's what i
do i make
another levels adjustment and i'm going
to go ahead and bring the gamma slider
down
and then i'll bring the black slider
down just a little bit so that this mid
area is also crunched down to
just about the level we need it we don't
want to go too much and lose data
we want to bring it just to the point
where it turns black
but you notice that down here it's too
crunched
so what do we do well luckily since
we're using adjustment layers and we're
not baking in these levels adjustments
we can actually paint on to this white
card here with a black paint brush to
undo the effect it's actually really
cool and it's the best way to work in
photoshop
so i'm going to use the open close
brackets to
make my brush size smaller or larger
switch to black make sure you have this
white card selected
and now you'll notice if i paint on here
it's undoing the levels effect like it
was never there
so if we know that if we go with a very
soft
low opacity brush we can slowly erase
the areas where
we don't need it to be as dark and don't
need to be as crushed
now from here we definitely have some
spots that are too bright so i'll make
another levels adjustment
bring it below the gamma shift which is
there just for us to see things a bit
better
and we'll bring down the gamma on that
now obviously we don't want to darken
this stuff up so now this is actually
when you can use the gradient tool
we can go from black to white from one
side of the image
to the other and you can see how it
turns it on on one side and off on the
other
another trick is to hit ctrl i to invert
the entire adjustment layer to turn the
whole thing off
and then you just paint on the parts
that you want to turn on
you can go filter other offset and this
is the point where you can actually see
oh do we need to
keep making tweaks or is this enough to
work with and i think this is actually
pretty fine because this is
these three quadrants actually look not
bad and make sure to maintain these 16
bits
by saving out your image as a tiff file
now it doesn't matter what program you
use i know a lot of you guys use blender
i myself use cinema 4d but it's all
about how you use the tools
you have to create the art that you're
seeing in your head
so shout outs to these very talented cg
artists
who put together some awesome art with
these imperfections we just created
together
guys so have fun get out there and make
some surface imperfections it's a total
blast
but if you guys would rather just buy a
pack online i'm actually running a 50
off deal on my imperfection pack until
christmas
only it is a very high quality pack that
i'm very very proud of and it's
30 4k 16 bit images
that'll help you guys take your cg
renders to the next level the link
is in the description if you guys
learned something new then consider
subscribing
also leave a comment down below with
what you would like to learn next i
really enjoy putting these videos
together
happy holidays to y'all i hope 2021 is
gonna be a better time i'm sure it will
be
and i'll see you guys then have a good
one peace
[Music]
you